[Musique]
les hôpitaux
bonjour à tous bonjour bonjour le lien
aujourd'hui qui nous emmène faire une
petite promenade sur les bords de la mer
noire ont toujours nos petits coeurs du
monde tu voyais nous allons faire des
spécialités bulgare la soupe ou bien
[Musique]
tous à vos stylos il était une autre
fois une sous froid de yaourt un
concombre 3 oignons 4 tomates quelques
feuilles de menthe
deux cuillérées de noir ap une cuillérée
à café de cumin hui yaourt
[Musique]
du sel du poivre des cubes de glace
alors pour réaliser cette soupe froide
il nous faut plusieurs légumes d'abord
les concours que tu es poche devient
évident
oui et toi on s'assure de quoi oui un
homme est là là c'est parce que c'est
une soupe
trois autres voitures et l'amertume de
la peau ah oui alors la politique alors
tu vois tu as donc j'ai coupé son
concombre il prend des zones ion qu'on
aura pas oublié de faire tremper le
monde carvin et géniaux sont des légumes
pour verser des larmes de crocodiles et
des larmes quand même alors tu vois toi
[ __ ] été union et tu crois en des
tomates et une égouts en petits morceaux
puisqu'au fond tu n'es pas s'il faut que
ce soit complètement complètement mûr
alors tu fais tout ça tu penses tu
prends composent et qui va laisser
macérer faire macérer ça veut dire
laisser reposer pendant trois ou quatre
heures pourquoi c'est bien tu sais pour
que tout le jus s'en aille
ça ma soeur alors tu ajoutes rang de
dents de la menthe vous tapez ressentir
c'est agréable
oui je te fait pas sentir la siesta fait
sentir la vente
j'ai pris ça par contre oui je mets ce
moment oui je mets des noix c'est ou de
voix non sont les noiséens à des lois
mais nous allons voir si ça vous connais
pas tellement les noisettes et puis du
cumin curcuma qui va peut-être
m'expliquer ce que c'est c'est une fois
d'aromatiques toit entre panique
oui on fait le cul mais qui sait que le
cube elle en allemand ça ce document
aujourd'hui alors tu l'as donc macérer
oui alors que je suppose que c'est ma
ses réponses
trois quatre heures il va penser
maintenant tout passe donc ça repasse
après cette phase dure est-ce parce que
oui et alors lorsque tu enfiles bonne
purée alors lorsque tu apurer ses
bienfaits ne pensez pas mal il n'est pas
paru jeudi du poivre oui tu salle oui
toi tu fais toujours cette maladie
dit-elle ainsi alors voilà alors jeté
prépare à lutter mélange jeter préparer
il ne sait pas ce que ça se mange glace
et ajoutez-les estime de glace alors oui
parce que je nie tout puisque la nasa
sont stressés très très glacée à bord
est bonne et pour une soupe c'est rare
parce que moi j'ai personnellement
rappelle notre adresse n'hésitez pas à
nous écrire sur cartes postales sans
oublier votre nom et votre propre
adresse pour la réponse de baston loris
parce que j'en ai à la banque accuse un
cuissot fr3 hoeness 5 avenue du recteur
poincaré 75784 paris cedex 16 robien
général et voilà on pourra tous mais à
bientôt sur 100
[Musique]